معنا من القدس الدكتور محمد هلسه
الاكاديمي والخبير في الشان
الاسرائيلي صناع القرار في اسرائيل سيد
هلسه في ردود افعالهم كانوا يتحدثون فيما
يتعلق بالاعلان الاسرائيلي عن مقتل 24
ضابط وجندي اسرائيلي خلال 24 ساعه
بالتفاصيل المختلفه عن حاله من الصدمه عن
حاله حاله
الكارثه نظرا لهذه الحصيله الثقيله كيف
تابعتم ردود الفعل الاسرائيلي على
ذلك تحياتي الردود الفعل الاسرائيليه تذهب
باتجاهين اتجاه يستمر في سرديته القديمه
وفي ذات الشعارات القديمه بان ضروره احداث
الحسم والذهاب في هذه المعركه الى نهايتها
للقضاء على حماس ويرى في مقتل هؤلاء سببا
للدفع في المعركه الى الامام وتيار اخر
يقول بان الذي حدث يؤكد على ما قال
المجتمع الاسرائيلي وجزء كبير جدا من
الاصوات العقلانيه فيه بان هذا الذي يجري
هو عبث ويقود الى مزيد من الخسائر
والاثمان الباهضه التي تدفعها اسرائيل في
المواجهه ان على الصعيد البشري او على
الصعيد الاقتصادي او على الصعيد المجتمعي
الداخلي حاله التجاذب تتد في داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي واعتقد بان ورطه المستوى
السياسي في هذه المرحله واولئك تحديدا
الداعين للذهاب الى هذه الحرب ا تتلخص في
امرين الامر الاول هو هذا الفقد الكبير
الذي يليه المجتمع الاسرائيلي اهميه كبيره
اسرائيل يعني تولي قضيه الخسائر البشريه
اهميه كبيره بسبب مجموعه من العناصر اولها
هو طبيعه العقليه الاسرائيليه المسكونه
بعقده الاستعلاء وت فوق العرق الاسرائيلي
وينظر الى نفسه كانه تعب الله المختار
فيما الاخرون هم الاغيار وبالتالي فقد
النفس البشريه هو يعني ليس كما ينظر اليه
في الفقد لدى بقيه الشعوب فيكون الحروب
تحدث يعني خسائر بشريه لكن المجتمع
الاسرائيلي كمجتمع استيطاني يعني عملت
قيادات اسرائيليه فتره طويله على اقناع
هذا المجتمع للحضور للقدوم الى فلسطين
باعتبارها مكانا امنا للصنا الان ليس من
السهل ان يعني تسق هذا العدد الكبير من
الجنود وا امر اخر مرتبط ايضا بقضيه ان
جزء كبير جدا من الجنود الذين يقاتلون
ياتون من عائلات علمانيه الريديم
المتدينين الارثوذكس لا يخدمون في الجيش
والعائلات العلمانيه نادرا ما تنجب عدد
كبير من الابناء هي تنجب ولد او ولدين
وبالتالي حينما يفقد احدهم في داخل
المعركه وكان هذه العائله تنتهي بشكل كامل
لذلك ف قضيه الفقد مهمه جدا في الداخل
الاسرائيلي وهي تحذف صدا في اطار المعارك
التاريخيه ظلت قضيتان مهمتان في اطار
المواجهه الاول يعني تؤثران في طبيعه رده
الفعل الجبه الداخليه الاول متعلق
بمدى استمرار المعركه لان المجتمع
الاسرائيلي يميل الى معركه قصيره خاطفه
فيها كثافه نيران عاليه تقصد اهداف ولا
يحبذ الذهاب الى معركه طويله بكثافه نيران
منقص لما ترتبوا عليه من اثمان وهذا هو
الذي يجري الان معركه طويله ممتد بكثافه
نيران منخفضه ترتب اثمان كبيره جدا
اقتصاديه وبشريه على المجتمع الاسرائيلي
لذلك يحدث رده فعل
و العدد الكبير ايضا من الذين يسقطون من
الجنود الاسرائيليين هذا ايضا يحدث ضرر
نعود بنقطه اخرى في المستوى السياسي
الاسرائيلي ال القضيه الاولى مترتبه في
الاعداد الكبيره التي تسطل كاهلهم وتحملهم
مزيد المسؤوليه القضيه الثانيه هذا اثبات
الى
انه النظريه والفلسفه التي يقود من خلالها
والاستراتيجيه التي يقود من خلالها هؤلاء
الحرب ثبت فشلها وهي تسقط امام جمله يعني
الخسائر المختلفه التي تقع في داخل الجيش
الاسرائيلي يوميا ضخ المستوى السياسي
والعسكري المجتمع الاسرائيلي بان وثيره
الحرب ذاهبه حتى وان اثبتت فشلها دكتور
هلسه بحسب مراقبين ولكن هناك اصرار على
مواصله هذه الحرب من قبل نتنياهو واركان
حكومته من اليمين المتطرف في اسرائيل على
مواصله هذه الحرب كنت قد اشرت قبل قليل
الى حاله التجاذب حاليا في اسرائيل ما
الات هذا التجاذب في هذه
المرحله ايه الذي تابع المشهد الاسرائيلي
بالامس قبل ان يعلن بشكل رسمي عن هذه
الارقام وهذه الاعداد كان هنالك موقفان
موقف في داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي وتيرته
حده يعني ضغطه و اشكال ومواقف مختلفه
اقتحامات وصراخ وتجاذب واتهامات وهذا يعني
ينقل الحراك في الداخل الاسرائيلي نقله
نوعيه باتجاه الضغط وفي المقابل نتنياهو
حينما يستشعر هو اركان اليمين الذي يود
هذه المعركه لا تنته حينما يستشعر حجم هذا
الضغط يبدا ايضا
يعلو ويرفع نبره يعني دي وبينغ فير بالامس
لما قال بان وقف الحرب يعني تفكك الحكومه
هذا جزء من تناغم والتقاطع مع موقف
نتنياهو وكان نتنياهو يقول يعني لدي ايضا
مجموعه من المجانين انجاز التعبير
المتعصبين اليمينيين في داخل الحكومه وعلي
ان خذهم بعين الاعتبار في اطار يعني
القرارات السياسيه المصريه التي قد تتخذ
في هذه المرحله الذي جرى الان في مشهد
المواجهه في الميدان يرجح كثفه المواجهه
التي تجري داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي والضغط
ال الموضوع فقط باليمين المتطرف من اركان
حكومه نتنياهو الذين يتما تتماهى مواقفهم
مع موقفه وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي ايضا
والجميع يعرف حجم الازمه بين نتنياهو وجلن
في هذه المرحله ايضا يؤيد استمرار هذه
الحرب ويقول مثلا ان الحرب في غزه ستحدد
مستقبل اسرائيل القادم كيف تنظرون الى
ذلك جيد المشهد الاسرائيلي الداخلي لا احد
فيه يستطيع ان يرفع طيرته بالمعارضه هذه
الحرب بشكل عاد لانه اسرائيل اعتاد دائما
على ان يضف في داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي
فكره التهديد الوجودي والتوزيع من ان هذا
الذي يجري هو حرب مصيريه قد تصر تقرر
مستقبل الكيان ودوله اسرائيل بلنت لا يخرج
عن هذه السرديه الذي يجري في المجتمع
الاسرائيلي يصور على انه حرب وجود
وبالتالي اما نكون او لا نكون لا احد وان
كان يقتنع بان هذه الحرب عبثيه يستطيع ان
يجاهر بمواقف ضد الحرب لذلك ترين حتى جزء
من اليسار الاسرائيلي الذي يذهب الى
معارضه هذه الحرب يذهب في اطار فجول ساتر
ولا ينقل مواقفه الى الميدان ولا يلتق ما
يجري في الشارع ليقود الشارع باتجاه وقف
هذه الحرب انما يساير المزاج الان في داخل
اسرائيل لانه تاريخيا ظلت في اسرائيل قضيه
الرايه الامنيه والتهديد الامني يسود
ويطغى على كل كل يعني التراث التي تطرح في
داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي وهذا مرده انه
يعني حاله التخويف التي تجري وما زال
نتنياهو يص في داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي
وتذكرين حينما ظهر قبل ايام في المؤتمر
الصحفي خوف المجتمع الاسرائيلي من ان وقف
هذه الحرب قد يؤدي الى اولاد الدوله
الفلسطينيه وان وقف هذه الحرب قد يقود الى
يعني المذبحه القادمه انها مساله وقت وان
حتى حدد المجتمع الاسرائيلي بان حديث مجرد
الحديث في الانتخابات قد يؤدي الى خساره
كل هذا الجهد وستذهب تضحيات الجنود
الاسرائيليين في سدم هذا يعني جزء من مزاج
عام في داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي والخروج
عليه يحتاج الى جراه ويحتاج الى مواقف
المواقف النظريه التي اظهرها عزن كوت لكنه
مازال ايضا شريك في داخل كابنه الحرب وجزء
من يعني اركان هذا النظام السياسي الذي
يقود هذه المعركه الذي يجري الان ربما
يدفع بعض الاصوات الى ان تخرج عن السقف
الذي رسمه المجتمع ورسمه نتنياهو بالمجاهر
العلنيه بان هذه الحرب يجب ان تتوقف
واعتقد بان الاثمان الكب البيره التي
يلفها المجتمع الاسرائيلي وبهذه الاعداد
قد تكون نقطه تحول فاصله ما بين المواقف
الخ سنعود لهذه الجزئيه المتعلقه بنقطه
التحول ولكن قبل ذلك اتوقف مع هذا الخبر
العاجل اطباء بلا حدود تقول كوادرنا في
مستشفى ناصر افادت بانها تشعر بالارض تهتز
وبان احساسا
بالهلع يطغى داخل المبنى اذا اطباء بلا
حدود تقول كل اجنحه مستشفى ناصر في خاني
ممتلئه ولا سبيل لاجلاء الفريق الطبي
والمرضى بامان هذا هو الوضع المتعلق
بمستشفى ناصر بل مجمع ناصر في خان يونس
جنوب قطاع غزه وهذه شهاده اطباء بلا حدود
من عين المكان اعود اليك دكتور هالس وكنت
تتحدث عن النقطه التي ممكن ان تكون يعني
نقطه
تحول ما الذي يحدث او يمكن ان يحدث فارقا
لايجاد نقط نقطه تحول في مسار ما يجري
الان بالاحرى كيف يمكن وقف هذه الحرب في
تقديرك في تقديري الذي يقرا المشهد
الداخلي الاسرائيلي يصل الى استنتاج بان
الجبهه الداخليه الاسرائيليه بدات تد صبها
وبدات تخرج عن يعني جدران السدريه السرديه
التي بناها حولها نتنياهو وبناها اليمين
القومي الديني في اطار متابعتنا التاريخيه
ل يعني تريس ال جهات التي جرت بين اسرائيل
والمقاومه اي ظلت الحال الداخليه
الاسرائيليه مضبوطه ومن ضبطه وتحكمها ربما
مجموعه من المعايير التي تسمح باستمرار
الرهان على مواقف داخليه اسرائيليه منسجمه
مع مواقف القياده الاسرائيليه اولها مدى
استمرار هذه الحرب حرب طويله هي مساله
تنهك المجتمع الاسرائيلي وتكلف اثمان الذي
يجري الان هو حرب طويله لم يعتدها المجتمع
الاسرائيلي المجتمع الاسرائيلي واسرائيلي
اعتادت ان تخو رب قصيره خاطفه في ارض
العدو وتعود منتصره الذي يجري الان هو
صوره منعكسه تماما عن مساد السابقه
المساله ثانيه مدى ما يحقق الجيش
الاسرائيلي من مكاسب على الارض وواضح جدا
بانه مع مضي ما يقارب ال 110 ايام على هذه
المواجهه ما زالت يعني الاثمان التي
يتكبدها الجيش الاسرائيلي في العتاد
والمعدات والجنود وكل والمفسر الاقتصاديه
ايضا تزيد من ورطه المستوى السياسي و
وتعظم الف وبين الجبهه الداخليه وبين
القياده السياسيه والعسكريه المساله
الثالثه المهمه هي مدى يعني فعليه
الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي مدى مقدره الاقتصاد
الاسرائيلي على الاستمرار في اداء دوره
وتقديم خدماته وا يعني اقتصاد متزن وا
يعني يسمح بتقديم الخدمات الذي يجري ايضا
في هذا المجال هو ان الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي
يان وتحت وضعه الخسائر المختلفه التي
يدفعها المواطن الاسرائيلي تبدو حاله من
التململ والمعطيات الاقتصاديه تثبت يوميا
بانه الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي يتكبد خسائر
كبيره في ظل هذه المواجهه المساله الرابعه
والمهمه مدى قناعه الجمهور الاسرائيلي
وايمانه بان هذه الحرب مبرره يوميا تتفكك
السرديه الاسرائيليه والروايه الاسرائيليه
بتبرير ما يجري يعني بدا جزء كبير جدا من
المجتمع الاسرائيلي حتى في اطار يعني
استقاه للمعلومات يبحث عن المعلومه التي
تاتي من الطرف الفلسطيني يحاول الدخول الى
مجموعه التواصل الفلسطيني يحاول استكفاء
الخبر من مجموعات تواصل عربيه فلسطينيه
عما يجري في الميدان لانه ما يدرك بان
هنالك تعتيم وحجم عما يجري ولا يسق في
المنظومه السياسيه ولا العسكريه انا تابعت
حتى بعض المجموعات الاسرائيليه جزء منهم
يقول عن انه اطلاله المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي العسكري الاسرائيلي هي يعني
الوانه مشروخه تعود بذات الكلام يوميا ولا
جديد فيها حتى يعني المؤتمرات الصحفيه
التي يعقدها جلنت ونتنياهو وجنس باتت لا
تاتي بجديد للمجتمع الاسرائيلي وبالتالي
هو بحاجه الى معلومه فيها مصداقيه وفيها
ثقه التوثيقات التي تحدثها المقاومه وتظهر
المقاومه تتاكد المجتمع الاسرائيلي من
خلال الاعلام عن اسماء من القتلى
والاصابات داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي
وبالتالي هذا يؤكد على سرديه المقاومه
وعلى انه هذه الحاله المتماسكه في الداخل
الاسرائيلي اخذها في التفق وقد تنذر بتحول
يسمح ل يعني اطاع نتنياهو عن شجره الطر
ووقف هذه الحرب شكرا جزيلا لك من القدس
الدكتور محمد هلس الاكاديمي والخبير في
الشان israili wana